of the climate for here and right now
beautiful view from our camera at the
red rock resort a little bit of a breeze
lots of blue sky but the storm clouds
over the higher elevations we'll get to
the future cast in a moment 103 degrees
at reed international seven degrees
warmer than 24 hours ago lots of numbers
over the century mark close to it up in
centennial hills mountains edge rose
ranch 98 out of the lakes 97 for
summerlin and again we're keeping an eye
out for some of these storm clouds to
potentially spill over here into the
valley first nevada and beyond kind of
thought the death valley would be hotter
than that 104 right now 92 up in lincoln
county caliente mesquite year 10 degrees
warmer at 102 same number in sandy
valley for up matching r-103 so in the
next 45 minutes or so the future cast is
showing the potential for a storm to the
south of us but this has already been
diminished in the last time we looked at
it maybe by two there'll be a storm cell
in the heart of the city but moving to
henderson by three o'clock this
afternoon and then completely out of
here by five o'clock this evening ted
florento keeps you posted throughout the
remainder of the day at 103 right now
which is the normal high for this time
of year we think it's going to get up to
106 after 105 yesterday low this morning
at 87 almost 10 degrees warmer than
normal still no threat to the record for
today's date at 1 15. so the storms we
see popping up right now are definitely
going to be more afternoon heat
generated so we do have to keep an eye
out for the remainder of the day for
your family and friends while there are
some severe storms going on for parts of
minnesota wisconsin and into the upper
peninsula of michigan and possibly
heading towards dallas as well let's
take a look at your eight day forecast
now including the fourth of july we
believe there'll be some lingering
moisture but not as many chances for
rain tomorrow 106 still the high also
106 on thursday
maybe drying out the atmosphere a little
bit high temperature slipping a little
bit 4th of july looks to be a high
around 100 but again heather we have to
keep an eye on the sky for this
afternoon for potential strong gusty
winds sharp temperature drops and
potential lightning and hail around
storms okay eyes to the sky nate thank
you still ahead